- Vorsicht.
Ja … Gut.
- Ach herrje …
Was ist denn mit dir passiert?
- Es ist nichts, nur ein kleiner Unfall.
- So sieht es aber nicht aus.
Hallo, Lisa!
- Hallo. Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Mir geht es gut. Aber Nico …
- Der Arzt sagt, es ist nicht gebrochen.
- Der Arzt sagt auch, du sollst
dich ausruhen.
Dr. Grube hat Nico Schmerztabletten
und eine Salbe verschrieben.
Wir waren mit dem Rezept schon
bei der Apotheke.
Nico, du darfst dein Bein nicht bewegen,
okay?
Nimm die Tabletten dreimal täglich.
Und die Salbe sollst du abends vor dem
Schlafengehen benutzen. Okay?
- Okay.
- Das machen wir.
Soll er die Tabletten morgens, mittags und
abends vor oder nach dem Essen nehmen?
- Nach dem Essen. Danke für Ihre Hilfe.
Ich muss jetzt gehen.
Aber wir sehen uns nachher, okay?
- Ja, gerne!
- Ich komme mit und besorge
uns etwas zu essen.
- Darf ich mitkommen?
- Du musst dich ausruhen!
- Tschüss!